hi I'm Zack and I'm single as [ __ ]
I'm 25 years old and I've never been in
a long-term kind of relationship but I
think I'm ready so I've been trying my
best to get back out there or just out
there I was using OkCupid the other day
and noticed an odd feature so I sat down
with the site's co-founder and date
Elizabeth or Christian rudder to get
some answers I'm sure you've heard the
idiom opposites attract keep it account
for that idea that maybe people who are
complete opposites are the ones that are
attracted to each other we have this
enemy percentage which is the third of
the three percentages it's basically how
much we thank you guys to pay each other
you can sort by enemy for sentence so
you've made it very easy I can search by
who I would hate the most
yeah you can put you can find that
person on OkCupid when can I see so I
devised a plan use okay Cupid's enemy
filter to track down my dating nemesis
ask her on a date and settle once and
for all if opposites attract so do you
think this experiment is gonna work all
right we're gonna try and find a nemesis
let's do it already I'm seeing people
who are 89% enemies with 0% match that's
pretty outstanding could you date
someone who was really messy I said yes
she said no really that's why we run in
these he used foul language I said [ __ ]
yeah she said no that's an issue for now
I'm looking for someone who won't be
afraid to watch and pay $5.00 it takes
to play with me on my naughty cam show
she wants me to pay to go on a date with
her you think it's a bot yeah turns out
finding a high percentage enemy is
harder than I thought a lot of the
people who are my highest percentage
enemies either only filled out like for
questions or our porn robots which is
not what we're here for
fat fetish 88 well you know I'm gonna
check oh my god you guys I got a message
Jahna she put like little emojis in her
profile I don't like that do you feel
that having sex with someone you have
known less than one year would be too
soon
no that's crazy she said yes protesting
civil rights issues is super important
she says protesting for civil rights is
just for pretentious snobs who won
attention
I found the worst person on OkCupid she
said I can't even with you right now sir
but anyways have a great day no no no no
no I cannot lose her Hillary Hillary
okay so I found this woman she's awful
listen all answers are good answers your
answers they're just different just as I
suspected you must have made an account
for an experiment dude she's flirting
with me okay she's flirting with me but
yeah count me in we got one we're done
here Zach in trionic let's see so I'm
about to go on a date with my nemesis
and I'm really excited to put it kindly
Rihanna seems awful she doesn't seem to
believe in premarital sex I've only had
premarital sex she's against smoking pot
I'm not even though we're in opposition
because we're in such opposition will
that lead to a level of attraction I'm
excited let's meet her thirty thousand
couples will have their first date
tonight because of OkCupid 3000 of them
one long-term together that's every day
Rihanna
hi there's there's no one perfect match
there's not even a thousand perfect
matches with tens of thousands of
perfect matches for every person out
there shall we the first time I saw his
profile I was like bro I can't even
review right now hopefully we don't kill
each other
hopefully not or if you do you kill each
other at the same time so there's never
to prosecute yeah I know we have a
lovely picnic set get some wine going a
light you know like wine I don't like
going like that at all
okay when I'm talking to my nemesis do
you think this is the opening hey okay
keep it says we should hate each other
how's it going yeah no I think that's
very good that may be [ __ ] you
are you comfortable here get comfortable
good look underneath that hurts me if I
sit like that I'm Asian so this is how
Asian sit well this is how I sit what uh
what do you think about my profile
pictures cute yeah yeah sexy or adorable
adorable are you down to have sex on the
first date but you're not gonna say that
we found that do you like the taste of
beer correlates most highly with would
you be up for sex on the first day you
so you don't like wine do you like the
taste of beer now not even not even a
little bit I thought it would be
interesting to look at the questions
that we answered differently and if
you're cool like we could just talk
about it let's do it well we all know my
name is Rihanna are you named after the
pop no no no did anyone go that you
don't get down with RiRi somewhere along
the way the conversation turned and
Rihanna and I start having a really nice
time do you not like Backstreet Boys
I loved what was it guys name Nick now
I'm gonna do this you're more
comfortable now it was you said you like
hickeys I guess the thought on videos
tonight but then like everyone sees you
have a hickey that's why you do it under
why it can be hidden then you start
seeing someone you really like how long
would it take before sex the thing is I
would have to be really really
comfortable with the person you want to
make sure that someone's not just using
you for sex and like you know and it's
not a fun feeling sounds like a lot of
the differences that we have are kind of
just misunderstanding the way you
answered the question after I say it
with communication talking to someone
conversation is the best way to to get
to know a person so Rihanna this was
really great you want to move on to the
next portion of the day
so that was great
Rihanna and I had a totally fun normal
date I came in expecting someone that I
would hate I thought there was gonna be
a lot of yelling but it was a really
nice time the fact that we were
opposites on paper made me want to get
to know her more and then as we spoke
more the focus switched from things that
we have in opposition to things that we
have in common and it turns out we have
a lot in common
I'll take you a bit sip that second Oh
we'll have a bad date but it wasn't
right it wasn't true we had a lot of fun
so do opposites attract I don't know but
I had a good date and that's all that
matters so
thanks for Jana yep great good job you
ready let's do this
okay zero serving zero whoops back